I am fascinated by last words
my favorite last words ever I go to seek
a great perhaps you must be the new
roommate
welcome to Coal Creek miles I call a
purge the colonel in his irony who is
that Alaska young Alaska my reputation
precedes me
[Music]
what's up scruff you grow this summer
bud you'll have to excuse them pugs they
had everything a life handed to him
looks like oh go north there has been an
outbreak pranks on campus I hope you two
were staying out of trouble
ah damn I didn't think you could look
any more handsome see one Boulevard you
know that his last words I how will I
ever get out of this labyrinth what do
they mean what's the mystery isn't it
which is he trying to escape the world
or the end of it I'm interested in those
things too
you ever gonna ask her out I Lara how
could I say no
what Alaska say about dressing fresh
mistake do realize you're going on a
date with Lara and not Alaska right
maybe the girl I was supposed to be with
is right in front of me
trust me buzz hang on to your innocence
as long as you can
how will I ever get out of this
labyrinth
what if Bulevar wasn't talking about
life or death but that part in between
what if his suffering he made you suffer
[Music]
did you hear about the students who were
kicked out going home isn't an option
Lasky's gonna get what she deserves
it's worth the same we are not the same
because I would never do what you need
we are lost in a maze so how do you get
through it
she made us accomplish this but you have
to live without the rest of our lives
tonight channel sadness you guys don't
trust me something terrible is that it's
not fair you don't have a choice it's a
zero condition and when your heart
breaks you have to find a way to keep
living
[Music]
you